であって 別に先の常識の方で言ってたの
マサードルーパーって
そこはワットですか  で
眼耳鼻舌身意もワットと言うんです
チャックワット ソートワット
ガーナワット ジワワット
カーナワットと言うんですね
それでチャック ソート
ガーナ ジワの場合は 眼耳鼻舌身の場合はこの情報は決まってるんですね
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
嗅ぐことできるものと
でも我々はその五つだけではなくて
また知ってるでしょ いろんなことは
例えば考えているもの
概念は目で考えてるわけじゃないでしょうに
耳で考えてるわけじゃないし
あ これは美味しいですとか判断するのは舌で判断するんじゃないでしょうし
ですから 眼耳鼻舌身だけではなくて
それ以外にも心が働いてるんです
ここで言ってるのは 残念ながらその心も物質に基ついて働いてるんだよと
いわゆる我々考える時でも
物質に基ついて考えてるんだよということですね
ですからハデーワットということを言ってるんです
別に扱ってるだけで 六つにしたっても同じことなんです
例えば常識は六つありますよ
で言ったっても構いません
五つではなくて ハデーワットの場合はこの見える
聞こえる 嗅ぐ 触れる その五つの機能以外の認識はハデーワットでやってるんです
見える 聞こえる それから嗅ぐこと
それから味わうこと それから触れることですね
それ五つの認識ですね
でも それ以外の我々には膨大な認識があるんです
その認識はこの物質にハデーワットという物質に拠り所にしてやってるんだ
また分からなかったところ
何かあるならば説明しますので
質問とかあるならばいくらか
ここら辺難しいと思うならばいろいろ聞いてください
で 今までは一応大事な物質の区別をしましたし
で これからはまあそんなに大事ではないんだけど
まあ次に出てくるのはミョウシキという
ジーヴィテルーパなんです
ジーヴィテルーパ 日本語の言葉で命って書いてね
ミョウシキと読むんですね
で それも物質的なあるエネルギーで
で あの物質の場合はもう何か生きているという意味なんですね
意味で言えば生きているエネルギーなんですね
いわゆるこの我々の体ってのは不思議なもので生きてるんですね
生きてるということは
区別するためには石とかね
そういうものと比べれたら
石っていうのはそのまんまなんですね
自然的にどんどん減っていくかもしれませんだけど
何も変化がそれ以外変化がないんですね
我々の体っていうのはそうじゃなくて
生きていて いつでも何か壊れると新しいものを作って
体新しくしちゃうんですね
それは死ぬ時までやってるんです
死ぬ時までも この我々の物質がどんどん変化するんだけど
この石やら机やら そういうものの変化とは違う変化なんです
植物も同じで変化はするんだけど
それは石の変化と あるいは死んだ植物の変化とは違うんですね
その変化なんですね あの妙色というのは
いわゆる命として変化するんだけど
別に死んでいくわけじゃなくて生きているんですね
ですから まあそれはそれは分かりやすいと思いますよ
例えば生きている植物がありまして
それはもう瞬間的にそれは変化していく
物質的なエネルギーですから
ずっと変化している その植物を我々はもうハサミで切って置いておく
置いておいたっても それまたそれでも変化はしていくんだけど
その時はあの変化はもう変わるんですね
それはもう枯れていって
どんどんもう消えていっちゃうというかね
でも植物として土の上にいる場合は
その変化はまた違うんですね
生きているものだから
で 細胞から考えて 我々の細胞は死にますし
死ぬんだけど その代わりに新しい細胞が生まれてくる
で 本当に死んじゃったら
その時も細胞は壊れていく
あの壊れ方 壊れる方法と生きている時の壊れる方法というのはすごい違うんです
一旦死んじゃったらもうもうすぐ壊れるだけで壊れて細胞でないものに変化してしまっちゃう
だから腐ってすぐ消えていっちゃうんですね
私の細胞は死んじゃうんだけど
死んだ細胞もそんなに臭いとかっていうことではなくて
それさっさと体から捨てて出してしまって
その代わりに新しい細胞を作る
人は年取ると何になるかというと
例えば小さい時は新しい細胞がたくさん生まれる
いわゆる死ぬ細胞よりものすごい生まれる細胞の量が大きいんですね
そこで我々は人は成長しているんだと言うんですね
それでどんどんこの死ぬ細胞と生まれる細胞の割り当てがもう変わるでしょう
いつか死ぬ細胞と同じぐらい細胞が生まれるようになってくる
それで我々は成長は止まったと言うんですね
もう成長は止まりましたと
なぜならば いつ見たくても
その人は全く前と同じなんですね
ということは その人の細胞はそれでも死んでいくんだけど
死んだ量と同じぐらいの量が新しい細胞が生まれてくる
我々わからなくなっちゃう
それでもう成長は止まっているという
それではどんどん死ぬ細胞の方が大きくなって
生まれる細胞の方が少なくなっていく
それであの人年取っていくんだ
体が弱くなってるんだとなってしまっちゃうんです
で あの死ぬ細胞の量が大きくなる
例えば人が死にかけてる時は
もうみるみるうちに体が弱っていって
1 日で 2 日間でもう体が動かなくなっちゃって死んでしまっちゃうんです
その場合は死ぬ量は多いんですね
でも生まれません 新しい細胞も
そういうことでもうその人は完全に死ななくちゃいけない
古い細胞はもう動かなくなっちゃいますから
そのエネルギー 新しいものを作り出すエネルギーは生命エネルギーなんですね
この生命エネルギーはここでは物質エネルギーなんです
仏教では 2種類あるんです
精神的な生命エネルギーと物質的な生命エネルギー
まだまだアビダンマではこの物質論ばっかり喋ってるんだから
ここで言ってるのは生命エネルギー
物質的なエネルギーなんです
それは妙色というんです
だからこのそういうのはこの知恵で理解するもんなんで
知恵っていうのは理屈ではないってことなんですね
皆様にも誰にでもあることで
じゃあこういうことなんじゃ
こちらにあるこの机と自分の体も同じ物質でしょうと
それは理屈上も同じ物質なんですが
でも何か違うでしょ？一つの植物持ってきたその植物と机は同じ物質なんですが
やっぱり違う 命として違う
あの命って何ですかと
わかりませんだけど 我々はそれをきちんと知ってるんですね
これは生きてるんだと
これはもう死んでるんだと
きちんと知ってることだから
それは知恵の世界なんですね
言葉では説明できない
でもはっきりと知っている
自分が生きていること
そのエネルギーなんですね
ですから あんまり合理的に言葉でこういうことで
こういうことだとは言えないんです
言葉というものは全然大した知識ではないんだからね
そこら辺質問がありますか
命という物質的なエネルギー
で それでも生命の説明はほとんど終わったんです
それぐらいの物質エネルギーをまとめたら
もう正真正銘の生命なんです
基本的な小さい果報から始めて
認識する物質を入れちゃって
で それから分別する物質を入れて
それから考える心の働きの物質も入れたところで
次にこの命としてのこのものが
この物体がもう生き続けているんだから
そのエネルギーも入れちゃったところで
もう生命としてそれ全部もう一応終わり
それで生命の物質的な構造終わるんだけど
次に出てくるのは終わったんですが
アーハールルーパなんですね
アーハールルーパというエネルギーのこと
アーハールっていうのは
英語ではTAKE IN 摂取するという
もう というか導入するというか
受け入れるということなんですね
日本語の名前は食 食ですか
食 食色 食色ですね 漢字で食ということはどういう意味か僕はわかりませんだけど
このパーリ語 サンスクリット語で食べ物にはアーハールと言うんですね
アーハールっていうのは外から中に入れるという意味で
アーハルティということ動詞から作ってるんです
パーリ語 サンスクリット語全部動詞であることを僕は何回も言ったと思いますけどね
名詞はないんですから
ハラティという まあちょっと同じ仏教ばっかりだったら面白くないんだから
ちょっと違うこと ハラティという動詞があります
このハラティという動詞ですね
この動詞は まあもっと詳しく言えば
このというあの五蘊から出てくるんで
ハラティっていうのは何か運ぶという意味なんですね
動かす 運ぶという意味です
そのハラティという言葉の前に
この意味のprefixと言うんだけど
ちょっとした言葉を付け加えるんです
アっていうのは中へという意味なんですね
ハラティにハラティという言葉にアという字をつける
アという字をつければ中へ
そこで中へ運ぶ 中へ運ぶものにアーハルというんです
自分の方向へ運ぶ アーハルティっていうのは自分の方向へ運ぶ
そちらの逆の言葉がアパハラティなんです
そういうことで このそれがわかれば
すごいサンスクリット語
パーリ語を勉強しやすいんです
ハラティという これまず勉強しておきます
運ぶっていうこと それを動詞決まってるんだから
動詞たくさんあるわけじゃないんです
アというのは中へ それにアパ APA
アパというものがつけちゃったらアパハラティになっちゃうんです
アパハラティ アパハラティっていうのは自分から外へ捨てるっていう意味なんで
その場合は で この場合は中へ運ぶと
アーハルティっていうのは中へ運ぶ
アパハラティっていうのは外へ運ぶということは自分から外へだから捨てるという意味なんですね
それでゴミに 何 何言うんですかね
捨てるもんでしょ ですから
これと同じくアパハラといえば
それはゴミなんです アーハラといえば食べ物なんです
それで哲学の世界でも論理の世界でアパハラという言葉をよく使うんです
いわゆる間違っているものを何とかして排除しなくちゃいけないんですね
質問でも選択質問でしょ
そこで選択の中で あ これは違う
これは違う これは違うと
あの働きにも哲学的な論理学的な働きだから
こういうことで これではなくて
こういうことで これでもなくて
これですと決めるがやるんですね
あの論理構造はサンスクリット語でアパハラナというんですね
アパハラナと いわゆる
あの 何て言うんで 愛情ですね
そういう まあ日本語でもそういう論理学的な言葉ありますけどね
ですからもうそういう風に言葉作るんです
サンスカリト語 パーリ語で
ちょっと動詞だけ知っておけば
別に辞書を一生懸命引かなくたっても
もうなんとなく意味をわかってしまうんです
全部もうどんな名詞でも
ちょっといじってみると
そこからもう動詞が現れてくるんです
そういうことで インドの文化では哲学と宗教は発展して
抽象的に 動詞は形ないんだからね
動きだから 描くこともできないんです
黒板に 三角形とか四角形とかね
歩くというふうなものをどうやって描くんですか？描けません
だから 歩く人を描けますか？描けませんよ
歩く形の止まってる人は描けますけどね
ですから 漢字の文化とは違うんですね
漢字の文化は静止文化です
止まってるんです 全部漢字は
漢字は名詞の文化 サンスクリット語は動詞の文化
動きの文化 ですから 結構苦労しないとね
頭の中で全く違う文化のこの世界はわからないかもしれません
仏教の哲学も全部動きそのものなんですから
無常論だから 動きの論なんです
ですから チャートやいろんな絵柄
図柄 何もなく巨大な仏教哲学を喋ってるんですね
私も描くの下手なんですからね
いろいろチャート書いたりしてあげたいなとは気持ちはあります
その方が分かりやすいかもしれませんだけど
静止的なもので でもどこかですごく描きづらいというかね
描きづらい 描いたところで
みんな静止的にそれを受け取っちゃうんですね
でも本当に今そこにあるわけじゃないんです
ものは動きですから 実際にあるのは動きだけであって
止まってるものはないんです
だから 残念ながらどっちでも正しいということは言えないんです
漢文化の静止哲学も正しくて
インドの動詞的な哲学も正しいと
ちょっと言いにくいんです
やっぱり動きがなければ存在はないんだから
動きは簡単に軽く あまり深く行かないで見ると静止的になっちゃうんです
それは誤解だと 仏教でもヒンドゥー教でもとことん言ってるんです
走る人は描けませんから
どうしても 笑う人も描けませんよ
そういうのは動きなんです
でも そういう風に描くことになっちゃったんだから
それは笑ってるんだと
それはもうああだこうだと
だからそういう 例えば
だから日本では漫画文化はものすごい発展しているでしょ
すっごく発展してやって
漫画もう見たってわからないほどですからね
もうとにかく動きを表現しようと一生懸命やっていたんだから
もうほとんどみんな漫画ばっかしで
もう漫画描ける人も結構いて
それまたもうすごい上手であるしね
いくら上手にしたっても
やっぱりその中でも上手というのは動きを表現することですね
動きを静止画面でどう表現するかっていうことなんですね
とにかくそれはどう表現したって間違いであることも間違いなんです
まあとにかくアーハラ
それはアビダンマと関係ない余計な話ですからね
まあそこをお休みとして言っただけで
うーんとアーハラ・ルーパ
アーハラ・ルーパっていうのは
まあ食識 中に入れる物質という意味なんです
なんでその識を特別にしますかというと
別になくてもいいんです
でも 生命として生きているものはやる
誰でもやる仕事が一つあるんです
生きてるんだから 妙根じゃなくて妙色ありますから
我々はずっとこの体を新しくしなくちゃいけないんですね
新しくするためには やっぱり外から物質を入れなくちゃいけないんです
修理しなくちゃいけないんですね
部品入れなくちゃいけないんです
ですから この体にはもうお腹の中で生まれた瞬間からずっと外から物質を入れて入れて入れて入れておかないと生きているということにならないんです
ですから 外から物質を入れる
それに食べ物とかね 食とか何とか言うんです
入れるのは正真正銘の物質なんです
そこでアーハルルーパの幻滅というのは
幻滅にどんなものかとちゃんとありますけど
ここでは説明ないかもしれませんだけど
まあ言えばエネルギーなんですね
そのアーハルになるエネルギーもまたどんなエネルギーかまた決まってるんです
その後でそれは説明来る可能性ありますから
そこってところまで僕はまあ
であったら説明します
わかったらそこはやめますけど
で あの まあとにかくこの体っていうのはエネルギーとして見たら
エネルギーは逃げていっちゃうし
逃げてるとエネルギーを入れなくちゃいけない
逃げているエネルギーよりはたくさんのエネルギー入れちゃうと
もうこちらのエネルギーの塊が大きくなっちゃうし
入れる方が少なくなっちゃうと小さくなっちゃう
ですから まあ食べ物を控えると
どうせ我々はまあ痩せてしまっちゃうし
たくさん食べるとどんどんどんどん体が大きくなってしまっちゃうし
ということで そこでエネルギーとして
我々は純粋にエネルギーだけ吸収することができれば大変楽なんです
このここを体がエネルギーだけとして見て
肉の塊としてではなくて
あるエネルギーの塊であって
そこでエネルギーが逃げるんだと
じゃあ逃げるエネルギーは外から
宇宙からどこでもいいんだけど
入れてあげようと思ったら
もうすごいもう簡単で楽なんですが
我々はもう複雑な肉体的な構造をしているんだから
そうともうまくいかないんですね
ですから 何を食べるかということは決まってるんです
その 例えば我々にはご飯やら野菜やら肉やら
そういうものをお腹に入れたら
お腹の中でいろいろ通して
そのエネルギーをとってしまっちゃう
牛やら山羊やら羊だったら
葉っぱとかいろんなものを食べて
そういうものからエネルギーをとっている
私たちも牛と同じくものを食べちゃうと死んでしまっちゃうんですね
ですから そのその生命には
もう体の構造によって
どんな物質から自分がエネルギー取れるかっていうことも決まってるんですね
人間にしたっても そのその人間の体によって
やっぱり食べ物はまあ結構決まってるんですね
ある食べ物を食べたらもう消化できなくて
もう体が壊れる場合もあるし
同じ食べ物他の人が食べたら何のこともないこともあるんですね
好き嫌いとかね 出てきたりして
まあ消化しやすい 私の体にはこの食べ物悪いとかね
まあそういうものは当然出てくるんです
それはもうエネルギーは吸収できるかないかということなんですね
そこで生命が吸収するエネルギーは種類しかないんです
犬であろうが ミミズであろうが
人間であろうが カメであろうが
自分の体を維持するために外から吸収するエネルギーは一つしかないんです
ですから すべての生命はたった一つのものだけ食べればいいのに
そうはいかない で この梵天とか神々には食べ物はないと言ってるんですね
ということは すごい高次元だから直接エネルギーはもう吸収してるんです
ある梵天の神殿は光を食べてるんだという話があるんですね
光っていうのはすごく我々から見ればすごい細かい精密なエネルギーですけどね
光そのものを栄養になるというならば
私たちには想像できませんだけどね
ただ 光の中でいれば それをずっと生きていられるということなんです
ですから 梵天なんかはものすごい長時間生きていられる
寿命っていうのはもう 一光年
二光年とか長い光食べる梵天っていうのは
もしかするとまあもう十光年
二十光年とかね 長い時間生きてるんです
宇宙なんか破壊してて全く関係ないんです
で そういう風にこの生命の次元が高くなると
食べ物のは細かくなってしまう
低くなるともっと荒っぽいものを食べてしまうちゃう
ミミズなんかは枯れた葉っぱとか土とかね
そのまま食べてまあ生きていられるんだから
ハヤブサとかね 腐ってる
もう肉やら骨やらもう全部食べちゃったりして生きてるし
我々のはそれは食べられないし
そこで美味しく感じる場合は
まあそのその生命は自分の食べ物をおいしいと思っちゃうんですね
で 高次元というのは梵天なんですけども
彼らがもう宇宙の基本的なエネルギーに支えられているんですね
ですから長生きできるんです
いわゆるわざわざ食べる必要はないんです
その仕事はしない 食べるっていうことを
いるだけで十分です エネルギーの中に入れるんだから
ですから 我々みたいに六十歳で死んだとか
八十歳で死んだとかね
そんなに なんか短くはない
食べ物は荒っぽくなればなるほど寿命は短いんです
細かくなれば寿命は長いんです
人間でもすごく上等の食べ物を食べると長生きできるんだから
この上等の食べ物っていうのは
口で美味しい肉とかそんなもんじゃないんです
体に一番吸収しやすい
体に一番近いものなんですね
ですから 僕 普通に言うと自然に一番近い食べ物
あまり色々無茶苦茶料理もしないで
あーだこうだとかもう変化もしないで
できるだけ体の自然状態に近いものを食べていると
もう何のことなく長生きできる
ですから 戦争の前に生まれた方々は長生きして
今の人々はもう大樹になると思ってるんで
どうかわかりません 私も先に死にますからわかりませんだけど
この日本は世界一長寿国というんだけど
それはもう昔の人々はもうあまり贅沢しなかったんだから長寿はできるんだから
今は子供さえ成人病にかかってるんだから長寿できるわけないんです
ですから 俺もいちいち国会で考える必要はないと思いますけどね
長寿国家になるんだからどうしようか
どうしようかとか まあただ今の若者はかわいそうということだけでね
体が仕事をして支えなくちゃいけないんだから
自分たちがその代わりに廃業してしまったりして
ですから 若者は年取っている人々に対してすごく腹が立ってるのはそれなりに
もう戦争をしたのは自分たちじゃないし
そのツケを払わなくちゃ
関係ない人たちが払わなくちゃいけないし
大変不公平ですけどね
とにかくこの食べ物というのは
そういうことで 吸収しやすい
一番自分の体の構造に近い食べ物を食べると
このまあ長生きというのはできるんですよ
そこでこのアーハールルーパっていうのは
そういう栄養素で 食意識で
生命が自分の生命を維持するために
あるいはもう成長するために外から入れるエネルギー
それも基本的に言えば地水火風なんです
ですから 特別なエネルギーとは言えないんです
次から出てくるのはまあベースにまあどうでもいい不思議なんです
で さっさと行きましょう
パリッチェドゥルーパという一つあります
パリッチェドゥルーパという物質が潜ってるんですね
それは基本的なものじゃないんです
ただまあ これ分断色ですかね
日本語の名前は えっと
分断色と書いてますし
あの それは色という風に物質的なエネルギーじゃないんです
とにかく 物質的なエネルギーでもないのに
物質的なエネルギーとして
まあただラベル貼っていて
ですからいい加減な分析なんですね
そこでやっぱり注釈書もそれをちゃんと知ってるんです
ですから これは第一実
真実じゃないんだと こちらはあの
何説？えーと 虚説と言うんですか
し 施設というんだと いわゆる
まあ勝手にもう作ったもので
別に実際にあるものじゃないんだと
アビダンマとは実際にあるもの
第一に説を言うと もう初めから始めたのに
そういうふうなところもあるんです
で 分断というのはどういうことかというと
別にこの空間のことなんですね
空間というのは不思議なこと
このものがあると現れるんですね
もう例えば何もものがないと言っちゃったら
もう何も考えられないんですね
例えば今 じゃあちょっと想像しましょう
もう 何もなくなったと
その時の空間 その時に我々は今あるものが考えちゃうんです
今いろんなものがある
それから妄想して なるほど
何もない でも何もないかと
何もない宇宙空間かと思っちゃいますけど
それも物質から考えちゃうんです
ですから ここを色作ってるんです
なぜならば この空間を我々に考えられるのは物質の性なんです
ここに部屋があるんだと
この空間がなければ部屋とは言えないし
やっぱり壁でそれはちゃんと決まっておかないと部屋にはならないんですね
例えば何か入れ物がある
これは空っぽですよという場合は
中身のことを喋ってるんだけど
結局その空っぽでない外のものを考えた上で
空っぽというものは成り立っちゃうんですね
その 例えば紙の入れ物を持ってきて
この中はどうですか？紙の箱持って中は空っぽですよと
あ そうと言って それで紙
紙だからそれ燃やしてしまう
じゃあ今は中はどうですか？中存在しないでしょう
空っぽの中は そうすると
ですから 空っぽを空間というものは我々認識するためには
空間でない物質はなければできないんです
ですから 今の現代の我々が考えている宇宙空間とか無限空間とかには全部嘘なんです
その人々はこの智慧の立場から見れば
ただの宇宙の無限の空間と言いながら
有限の空間を考えているんです
無限の空間は考えることできないんです
考えるものは全部物質的なものに基づいて考えているんです
ですから 空間は誰が作るかというと
物質が作ってしまっちゃうんです
この部屋は狭いか大きいかというためには
私たちが部屋の中にいなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の体と体から考えれば
狭いやと ああ広いやと思うだけのことなんです
結局元になってるのは自分になっちゃうし
大きい小さいとかね そんな空間的な概念
全部 次にあるのはヴィンヤティルーパ
こちらこの標識と表現の表かな
まあ書いてあって 信表五表ですかね
2つあるんですね ヴィンヤティルーパ
テキストを見て これは 2つ
今まで書いたものは全部 1つです
回るとまた 2つです で
あの これまたまあちょっとおかしい式もの色なんですね
信表と いわゆる体で表す
表す 言葉で表すということなんですね
表すっていうのは このヴィンヤッティっていうのはコミュニケーションなんですね
知らせるって意味なんですね
知らせる物質という意味なんです
他の人に知らせる 知らせるということは
知ることをさせるという意味で知らせるなんです
で 体で知らせるといえば
例えばこの まあわかりやすく言えば
私たちは手でこうやって手を触れると
こっちおいでという意味になっちゃうし
手を体から外へ触れると
同じ触れ方なんです 出て行きなさいということになっちゃうし
それで体を動かしていろんなものを相手に知らせることできるんですね
で そこは一つの色として言ってるんですね
一つの物質エネルギーとして
なんでそんなことまで考えるかとかわかりませんだけど
で 別に特別な組織があるわけでもないんですね
でもちょっとした差があるんです
例えば私にこの まあこっちいらっしゃいという手の動きを
その気持ちじゃなくて
ただ何のことなくこうやって触れると
相手はもうただ手を振ってるだけっていう風に認識するんですね
でもこっちいらっしゃいという意味が
気持ちが入っちゃったらすぐわかるでしょ
その差があるんですね
例えば私はただこうやって手を横に触れたら
何の意味もないんですね
それで手を横に触れると
違いますよという意味もあるでしょ
あ 違いますよという場合は
同じ触れ方なんですけど
相手がそれすぐわかってしまっちゃう
ダメですよ 違いますよ
できませんよということで
それで あの 人に別れの挨拶するときも手を触れちゃうでしょ
同じ方向へ その場合  何て言いますか
別れますよと さようならという意味がそこにあるんですね
別に触れ方が変わったわけじゃないんです
それで人形を持って触れちゃったら全然通じないんですね
人形に ロボットに手を横に触れるようにしちゃったら
今このロボットはダメですよ
いけませんよと言ってるんだよと
今さようなら バイバイと言ってるんですよというふうにはならないんですね
そこはやっぱり まあ人間にはできるんですね
体で 体を持っていろんな言葉を喋られる
いろんなことを知らせる
その機能を見て それは特別な機能だから
人形から見たらその機能は人形を持ってないんですね
ですから それに心 え 表ですか
心表と呼んでカーヤ・ヴィンニャティと言うんですよと
パーリ語だったらカーヤ・ヴィンニャティ
カーヤ・ヴィンニャティ
ワチ・ヴィンニャティ
この中にある二つですからね
二番目はワチ・ヴィンニャティ
そういう二つありますと
カーヤ・ヴィンニャティっていうのは
あの 体で表現すること
まあエネルギーではエネルギーなんですね
ワチ・ヴィンニャティっていうのは言葉で表現すること
で 言葉の表現も我々は結構知ってるし
その まあ言葉っちゃっても
まあどうせ音だから あの
物質的なエネルギーなんですね
その音はいつでも同じ意味を通じているわけじゃないんです
それもちゃんと理解してほしいんです
言葉ですから 言葉はいつでもちゃんとした意味が持ってますということじゃないんです
例えばバカという言葉があるんですね
バカっていう言葉は辞書を引いてみたら
人を軽蔑する 貶す もう尻そぼる言葉なんですね
いけない言葉なんです
本当にいつでもバカっていうそういう意味ですか？そうじゃないんです
我々実際に使う時は意味はそれなりに変わっちゃうんですね
だから 本当に怒って人を批判するために
貶すためにバカですということも使えるし
何のことなくもう何やってるんですかとかね
まあという意味でも同じ言葉は言えるし
例えば自分が怒った時は本当に怒ったよとも言えるし
ただあまりにも楽しくて
それも怒りましたよとも言えるし
例えば自分にも気に入らないことを相手が誰かやっていて
本当に怒ります そんなことやったら言ったらもう本当に怒ってるし
もうもう怒りました怒りましたと言うと
別に怒ってないんです
ただもう楽しがってるだけなんですね
ですから このランゲージですか
言語とは違うんですね
言語から表現するときは
ですから 大体我々人の話を聞くときでも
もう辞書で話を聞くんじゃなくて
やっぱり心で聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
あの人心から何を表現しているんですかと
その知識ない人は 例えば私の言葉でもすごく失礼ですよとかね
大変もう良くないんだと
もっと丁寧な言葉を勉強してからの方がいいんではないかという人もいるんですね
そういう人はもう欲もあることは全然
まず私のことを知らない
それからもう全くもう世の中のことも知らない
すごいもう狭い範囲で生きてるだけのことで
そういう人に言われるんだから
私も全然自分を直そうとは思ってないし
言葉もうちょっと直した方がいいんじゃないかなとは思わない
そんなアホに言われてもバカバカしくて
それなりの理解ある人に言われたらすぐその場で直しますけど
直さないということもあるんですね
ですからこの そこは大事なことなんです
例えば 我々も人にいろんなことを言ったりするんだから
この人が自分に言ったことをしてほしい場合は
言語で言うんじゃなくて
やっぱりそこに意味はちゃんと心の中にないと通じないんですね
言葉の持つ意味というものも付け加えていいんですか？ 何？ 言葉の持っている意味ということがありますよね
バカがバカって言う意味でも解釈をしてもいいわけ？ それなんて
じゃなくて  それは  誰かが起こるアクティブなことですか
だからこの辞書にある言葉
いわゆる言語学である言葉というのは
あくまでも機械的で もうただの機械的なものなんですね
あれなんて言いますか
この子供たちが組み立てるプラスチックの
あれは何と言いますか
レゴですね あのレゴみたいなもので
たくさんなって それはいろんなものを作るだけで
言葉っていうのはそういうものなんです
でも実際にそれは人間使ってるんだから
人間使ってると違う意味はまた持ってるんですね
人間何か心で思って それを表現するために言葉を使う
その時は辞書の意味とは変わってしまっちゃうんですね
だから私たち言うのは正しい
実際に必要なのは このディクショナリで辞書で言ってる言葉ではなくて
自分が何をコミュニケーションしたがっているかという世界なんです
で 辞書っていうのはでき始めたら
いわゆる言葉として 学問として出来上がる と
もともと人間は考えた
感じた意味から始まりますけど
独立しちゃったら まあ機械的にどんどん発展して膨張していくだけのことなんですね
そういうことで 実際のコミュニケーションで使う言葉
いわゆるアクティブな部分ですね
ですから 人にすぐ すぐではなく
どんな人でも理解するのは
まずこの実際の言葉のこのコミュニケーションしたがっているところなんですね
ですから 我々わけもわからない言葉で喋っている場合でも
なんとか感じる時あるんですね
何とか感じるんですね
フランス語 ドイツ語がわからなくたって
その言葉でいろいろなんか言ってると
もう何とか感じちゃう
その何とか感じるところは
言葉を知ってるならばしっかりとわかるだけのことで
辞書を引いてはなかなか出てこないんですね
英語はなかなか使えないのはそういうわけで
辞書でやろうと思ってるんですね
心でやろうとは思わないで
それだったらもういくら頑張ってもうまくはならない
なぜならば そういう言葉は存在しないんだから
人は生きてる人は生きてる人と喋ってるんだから
僕はそれある日 ちょっと冗談で子供と子供からかったことがあるんです
自分の国である家に行ったところで
すごい大金持ちの大きな家で
うちの人はいなかったんですね
そこでちっちゃな子供がいて
いろいろ話すんですね
我々と 話してると犬ものすごい声で吠えて吠えて飛んできたんですね
飼ってる犬が それで子供は犬にもう静かにしなさいと言うんだけど
犬は言うことを聞かない
僕はあの子供に それはあなたのことをこの犬はわからないんだと
本当はこの犬は日本語よくわかるんだと
それはまあ あの子も日本から来たということも知っていたし
そしたら全然信じないんですね
僕は犬に日本語で喋ったんです
あの犬も生まれて初めて日本語聞いたんですけど
で 私が言うことちゃんと聞いたんです
聞いて吠えたりするのをやめて
もう遊び始めたんです
で 子供は目を青々にして
もう不思議で不思議で
どんなことか でもわけのわからない言葉で言ったら
犬はよく言うことを聞いてくれるんだと
で ただ向こうは面白がってやっただけで
実際に何がやったんですかというと
子供はもう偉そうに もう黙ってなさいとかなんとか言うだけで
もう犬に対するその愛情とかね
犬は理解する部分に自分の感情を合わせないんですね
子供は私たちにいつでも意識を合わせているんだから
僕はサッと犬に意識を合わせて
あんた何やってるんですか？静かにしなさいということを言ったんですね
そうしたら それですぐ私の感情は通じちゃったんですね
それは通じるんです ですから
私は動物と喋る時は全然遠慮なしに
ごく普通の言葉でいろんなことを言うんです
言うんだけど もうたまに私のお寺の長老も私にもあの人何やってるんですか？と
犬とそんなこと言ったってわかるわけないでしょうと
なんか僕をバカにしてからかったりする場合あるんだけど
僕は全然気にしない なぜならば
僕はすごいムスク たまにみんなさらにからかってやろうと思って
すごい自分の言葉といういろんなランクあるんです
まあこの家によってとか
教育によってとかの使う言葉っていうのはね
僕はすごい普通の人なんか全然使わない
すごい格の高い言葉でも犬に喋ったりするんです
で 聞いてる人々は私の言葉の使い方さえたまに笑っ
時もあるんですね で みんなもうアホなことやってると思ってるんだけど
結局どんな難しい言葉で言っても
犬は言うことを聞いてくれる
英語で言ったって同じこと
自分のところにいる犬に日本語で言ったって言うことをやってくれる
っていうことは やっぱり辞書の言葉じゃなくて
生きているところに言葉をね
自分が何を言ってあげたいかということで
そこら辺は通じるんです
だから他の言葉を勉強した場合
したい場合は この早く身につきたいと思ったら
それなんですね ポイントは
辞書を引かないこと 辞書じゃなくて
その言葉を持ってる感情を自分が感じてみる
感じたら自分の言葉なんです
それは 何のことなく 自分の言葉のように
自分の母国語の言葉のように使えるんです
ですから 最初はどうせ単語を覚えたりとかしなくちゃいけないんだけど
これ単語を暗記するんじゃなくて
そのその単語を持ってる感覚を感じてみる
体験として それで何のことなくその人の言葉を使えるんです
僕はタイに 1週間ぐらいいたんだけど
いろんな人はタイ語っていうのは全くわからないし
理解しようともしなかったし
でもいろんな人と喋るとすぐわかるんです
この人は記憶がある人で
この人はすごい性格はいい人だとかね
自分が全然知らないんだけど
タイ語っていうのは いまだに覚えてるんです
空港からタクシーに乗ったんです
乗って 私は行く先をタクシー運転手さんに言ったんです
若者でしたけどね そこで私が言った言葉
彼は繰り返し言ったんですね
お寺の名前 あのお寺の名前発音して発音した瞬間
僕の心にすごく あ この人はすごく
この なんていうの できてる人だと
すごい性格が正しくて立派な人だと
いきなりそういう共感というか
ただお金のために何とかしてタクシーを運転しようではなくて
自分の仕事に誇りを持ってもう大事な客さんを丁寧に運んであげるような立派な人だなと
すぐさったたったこのお寺の名前を言っただけで
サッと心に入っちゃうんですね
そこでお互いに会話できないんだけど
もう私には心が通じてるんですね
その人に私の心が通じてるかどうか
それは別の話ですけど
そこでもう店に行ったっても
この店から買うべきかないかっていうことはね
その店の人の言葉がわかってもわからなくても
まあすぐにわかる そこは隣の店に行きましょうと
ですから このそこら辺大事なんです
だから 人の違う言葉を勉強する場合の
この もうできない人々っていうのは
機械的に脳細胞でやりますからなんですね
辞書を暗記するんだから
日本でね あれはそうそうできないんです
いい大学に入りたがっている学生たちっていうのは
もう 入れたら 2冊 3冊ぐらい終わったんだと
もう暗記して暗記して
本がむちゃくちゃになる
新しいテキスト本をまた書いて買って
また暗記するんだと そこでどれぐらい単語を暗記したんで
やっぱり 2万  4万とかもう数も言うんですね
私は自分が 2万ぐらい英語の単語を知ってるかっていうことは全然わからないんだけど
どれぐらい？全然数えたこともないんだけど
で 考えたら その私が知っている人々が暗記している辞書というのはかなりの立派な辞書なんですね
じゃあ英語は誰がうまいかって
僕はもう何のことなく楽に使ったり書いたりするし
その人に何か英語で喋ったら
すっごい苦労して苦労して
もうやっと何か喋ったっていうことなんですね
ですから もう何やってるんですか
そこでテキストを読む時でも
これは主語で これは何語で
これはあれとか もうカットして分析して
こうだからこうであって
こうだからってもう日本語訳するんですね
じゃあ終わったんですか？って言ったら
じゃあこういう意味ですよと私に言うので
僕は違います その意味じゃないんだと
何の分析もなく これはこういうことを言いたがってるんです
この人は だからこの そこら辺なんで必要なのは
この表現の場合は 言葉の場合は
辞書でやるんじゃなくて
心でやるもんなんです
あの もう完全には忘れちゃったんだけど
昔このフランス語を勉強しようと思って学校に行って
行ったその日からもう英語を使わないんですね
そのところで これやりすぎと思ったんですね
この人々は フランス人で女の人が来て
いきなり もうあの人英語知らないでしょうか
わかりません 大体フランス人
英語あまり上手じゃないんだけどね
で これはダメだな 変なところに行ったなと思ったんだけど
やっぱり最初の授業ももう完全にフランス語で
でもその人も我々一言も知らないってことを知ってますし
やっぱり表現でね ずっとやっていたんですね
いきなり言った言葉 ワラという言葉なんですね
まあその言葉は同じ発音で
シンハラ語だったらとんでもない下品な人って意味なんですけどね
それでも面白がったんだけど
いきなりこの女性が 立派な女性が
でも その言葉を使った瞬間で
この何のためにこの言葉を使うかと
何を表現したかっているか
すぐもう入っちゃったんですね
そこで全然辞書で未だに知らないワラという言葉
VIOLLAなんですけど
どんな意味？でも使いますよ
使うことでちゃんとその表現する感情なんて英語でも Here You Are とかねありますね
で 日本語でもちょっと待ってとかね
あのねとか その辺なんで
あのねって何の意味もないでしょ
辞書を引いちゃったら
でもそうじゃない ちゃんとした意味があるんです
辞書にはない それ似てる言葉なんです
バラ で言ったら そこで次に彼女言ったのはレギャーデムアって言ったんですね
全然わからない 聞きなればガーデンマって言ってもわからないし
そしたらもう彼女はレギャーデムア
あちこち見てるんだよ
ああ 彼女の方を見てくださいってことです
ってすぐ分かったんですね
いきなりムアっていうことは自分ということも分かってしまったし
でもそれで別に後で家に行って覚えようとか何もなく
その授業はもう全部そのまま体に入っちゃうんです
それでも回 回 回になってくると
もう何のことなく 彼女はペラペラフランス語で言うわ
まあこちらはテキスト通りにやってますけど
短い言葉の世界なんですけど
やっぱりわからなかった言葉これっていうことは何もなかったんですね
そこで我々も途端にいきなりフランス語で喋り始めたんで
いつできたか全然わからない
ただもう結構喋るんですね
いろんなことを それで難しいことを
政治やらいろんなことを喋るようになっちゃったら
言葉わからなくなっちゃったら
その言葉だけ辞書で見るんですね
そこでわかったのは もうほとんど日本語
英語の単語に似てるってことなんで
発音だけ違うんですね
DIになったらね あの英語だったらサンという発音ですけど
あれはシオンと発音するだけのことでね
そこでまあまあ発音だけでちょっとフランス語風にしちゃえばフランス語ですよ
まあ全部はそうはいきませんだけどね
まあ動詞の変化はまた違うし
だから勉強するのは その場合の我々の私たちにとっては動詞の問題でしたし
動詞は別にサンスクリット語やってるんだから
もうそんなに難しくはない
動詞はサンスクリット語もパーリ語もほとんど似ているんだからね
昔々のアーリア言語だから
もうかなり音として似ているものがありましたから
それはそんなに ですから
すぐ勉強してすぐ忘れたんですね
全然使わなかったんだから
ですから このそこら辺ですね
こちらで考えてるのは
別に今は僕は余計なこと
けど そんなこと仏教で言ってないんだけど
どうやって違うことを勉強するか
でもお坊さんたちっていうのはかなり言語能力
昔からあったんですね
今もやっぱりお坊さんの方は結構こういう他の人々と勉強しようと思ったら
まあ大体まあかなりいい点数でもいっちゃうんですね
で 例えば昔スリランカへ仏教伝道した時はマヒンダ長老が来てね
これ紀元前の話ですから
インドから来てスリランカで説法したんだから
スリランカ人というのは別にインドという国があることも知らない一般の人々でしょう
どうやって説法したんですかね
一つみんな言うのは マヒンダ長老スリランカへ伝道するように決めた
決めたから 彼が 2  3ヶ月間どこか遠方へ行ったという話もあるし
そこで国の言葉をいろいろ勉強しただろうとかね
思うかもしれませんだけど
たとえ 3ヶ月間勉強したことにしたっても
仏教を喋りましたからね
やっぱりそういうマヒンダ長老は阿羅漢でしたし
やっぱり言葉ではなくて
やっぱり本当に表現するべきものは心ですということを知ってたんだから
で 今我々使っている注釈書を書いたブッダゴーサさんもインド人なんです
インド人でスリランカへ来て
スリランカでスリランカの言葉で書いてあった膨大な量のテキスト全部参照して
今現代にあるパーリテキストを作ったんだから
だからスリランカの言葉の抜群のプロでないとできないことなんです
で サンスクリット語の経典は全部漢文にしたでしょ
あれの裏にずっといたのはインド人でしたからね
インドのお坊さんたちだから
インドのお坊さんたちはやって
それで中国人が中国人の言葉に言葉らしく書き直したり編集したりして
今ある 言葉で生きていて
だから今の人々がわからない
わからないと言ったっても
で 僕はあれ大したことだと思いますよ
あの決まってる漢字っていうのは
一番この元の意味にできるだけ近い近い意味の言葉
漢字を探して探して入れちゃいますから
それからサンスクリットの文章は短いんだったら
それなりの中国の言葉は短いし
サンスクリットの偈文だったらちゃんとした漢文でも
それは偈文で文字数もきちんと決まって
えらい似ているようにやってるんですね
それあまりも似ているようにやってるんだから
もう反対訳もするんです
今 いわゆるこのサンスクリット語で原文なくなっているお経の場合は
中国語を読んで それをサンスクリット語にしちゃうんです
したところで 元のサンスクリット語のお経はまた現れちゃうんです
それぐらい正確にやっちゃったんですね
それはもう頭だけの言語能力でできるもんじゃないんです
辞書だけで どう考えたってもね
インド人が中国語に訳するっていうことは
なんか僕らは知ってるんだから
漢字勉強することはどれほど難しいかと
いくらでもすぐ忘れちゃうし
もうすごい嫌なもんなんですね
それで訳したっていうことは
もう私でもやろうとすればできるもんなんです
そういう気持ちがないだけのこと
でも怠けるのはもうずっと自分の人生そのままになってるんだから
だから私は漢字を勉強するときでも
やっぱりこの主観で そういう字をそのものを見るんですね
ですから 自分の読めるわかる漢字のパネルがものすごいたくさんあるんだけども
発音さえ知らない どうやってほとんど知らない
関係ない 言ってることはわかるんです
何言ってるかと じゃあそういうことで
この仏教では言葉も一つの物質になってるんですね
何色？語法と語法式になってるんです
次にあるのはヴィカーラルーパ
あ そう  5時までと思った
あ そうですか じゃあ はい
終わりました  [背景音]